all right let's do it
[Music]
welcome back to chasing our roots i'm
vanessa we are still in the bay area but
we're in san francisco visiting with
chef eskinder and seget from radio
africa and kitchen my food reflects kind
of a story about african cooking in
california city using the freshest
ingredients and then utilizing ethiopian
or african techniques today we'll be
making wild salmon with egyptian
alicia and harissa harusa is a north
african sauce
made from bell pepper chili flakes
cumin a little bit of garlic lemon juice
and olive oil and it has a really nice
beautiful aromatic and
spicy and zesty flavor it's showcasing
the abundance of california white salmon
from alaska and utilizing the flavors of
north african egyptian shows and the
dish itself i'm so excited to get
started let's get it okay let's do it we
have the wild salmon marinated with
saffron a touch of garlic lemon juice
and green olive oil we also have the
vegetable alicia and we're gonna just
cook it slowly over here the lentils
and the quinoa goes in the oven the fact
we do not have any a higher end quality
african restaurant in san francisco that
kind of actually got me gone all we have
to do is learn all the tricks and
continue to grow continue to travel
continue to try we can we can do
anything we want that's absolutely right
i love that okay and now we're gonna
saute
the wild salmon oh perfect you ready yes
uh right let's do it
and then we covered
how long are we going to cook the salmon
on each side oh not about 2-3 minutes i
think the decor
also reflects the way i grew up in
ethiopia my mother was a great gardener
and she always planted edible gardens
the decor
is for all the employees is always to
keep this place green so when we come in
here it looks like a park and we always
change the plants and we rotate them and
then we're gonna flip it
right here
nice and brown
exactly it's amazing you can even smell
like
the shallots and the garlic and the salt
from the vegetables the spices we use is
called burberry which is a national
ethiopian spice mixture which has a
bird-sized chili fenugreek cumin and
then we mix that in a tomato sauce the
salmon is finished what i'll do is that
tomato coffee which has a little bit of
the high risk end of what it is it's
very aromatic yeah it's very aromatic
this is a cumin and ginger right here
that's a
african aspect of it
got the burberry
i want to set the vegetables right here
thank you for your help
i get all the pieces
it goes right there
and the final touch will be the harissa
again just drizzled around you make this
one yes absolutely yeah okay is it super
spicy
it's medium spicy medium spice this just
gives it a little zingy zesty flavor so
a dish like this with all these fresh
ingredients has to be expensive it's
actually twelve dollars we know where to
source the best ingredients for
reasonable price and we're very
efficient okay i'm gonna start with fish
let's see
oh wow look how flaky that is
terrible i take it no no
there's subtle hints of the burberry and
harissa so you got that little bit of
heat with the automatic with the
aromatics and then you can taste the
lemon juice with burberry i love the
color of the swiss chard i really
appreciate you teaching us some really
great things thank you so much
absolutely thank you i had a great time
hanging out with japan skinner today
learning about harissa and burberry and
their flavors i'm not familiar with
fresh ingredients are right next door if
you know how to find them and use them
properly you can have great affordable
meals right at home
[Music]
do